- Mesdames M p p p p p p p p p r
l'accident nucléaire qui s'est
produit a a a centrale de
Tchernobyl.
- La situation s'est détériorée
y y y y y y y y y y y y y y y e
par rapport au nucléaire.- - - e
a retenu son souffle alors que
ce faisceau lumineux tombait
du ciel. La centrale nucléaire
de Zaporijia, la plus grande
par un missile russe.
Heureusement, les réacteurs
ne sont pa l l l l l l l l l l .
- Puis, le 24 février, l'armée
russe a pillé et opepepependant
plus d'un mois la centrale
désaffectée de Tchernobyl et
la zone d'exeseseseseseseseseset
fortement contaminée.
Pourtant, rappelle
ce spécialiste français,
le protocole de Genève
est clair.
MARC FINAUD, ancien diplomate
et professeur au Centre de
podedededede sécurité de Genève.
- Selon le droit international,
ces sites sont totalement
protégés. Il est interdit
de les cibler.
-  À la lumière des récentsévévs
aux catastrophes naturelles,
il y a matière à relancer
le débat sur la sécurité
nucléaire, selon certains
spécialistes.
MYKLE SCHNEIDER, spécialiste et
consultant en énergie nucléaire
- En Ukraine, on a 15 réacteurs
qui étaient en fonctionnement,
des grands réacteurs avec
des inventaires de radioactivité
incroyable. Toutes les règles,
toutes les règles d'exploitation
sont violées. Il y a aujourd'hui
plus de règles.
- Surtout qu'au nom de l'urgence
climatique, plusieurs pays
dont le Canada, veulent miser
sur l'énergie nucléaire, car
la production de cette énergie
émet très peu de gaz à effet
de serre.
Au Canada, on compte déjà
19 réacteurs répartis dans
quatre centrales nucléaires.
Trois d'entre elles sont
en Ontario et l'autre est
au Nouveau-Brunswick.
À la Commission canadienne
de sûreté nucléaire,
qui chapeaute la réglementation
des centrales, on assure que
les sites nucléaires sont
très bien protégés.
Deux niveaux de protection
existent : la sûreté
des systèmes et la sécurité d d.
- La sûreté, c'est vraimentsssss
les systèmes mis en place
fonctionnent bien, fonctionnent
de façon indépendante
et si jamais un système
ne fonctionnait pas, un autresye
la relève.
- Quant à la  sécurité physique
des installations, la commissior
des réacteurs sont contenus
dans de  très gros prestos
cylindriques en acier qui
peuvent supporter d'immenses
pressions.
Les centrales, elles,
sont recouvertes d'un bouclier
de ciment capable de résister
à toutes sortes d'attaques.
Puis, des pltitititititititions
d'urgence sont revus
annuellement, et doivent
répondre aux exigences de
l'Agence internationale
de l'énergie atomique.
- Certaines
exigées incluent la capacité
d'intervention armée
sur le site.
- Mais plusieurs experts
affirment que ces systèmes
de sûreté et de sécurité
ne sont pas sans faille
surtout s'il vient à manquer
d'électricité pendant une
période prolongée.
- Les panenenenenenenenergie
nucléaire vous disent oui, mais
regardez le réacteur, il est
protégé par d'énormes couches de
béton, mais ce n'e
des piscines de refroidissement
qui, elles, sont vulnérables
à des accidents, à des attaques
de terroristes et
des explosions.
- Dans csesesesesesesesesent
les barres de combustible usées
qui doivent être constamment
refroidies.cacacacacacacacacas e
de Fukushima en 2011 au Japon
en est un exemple concret.
Le séisme a détruit tous
les systèmes de secours rendant.
Les barres de combustibles
ont donc explosé et causé
des contaminations massives.
En cas de conflit,
il est aussi possible que
des malfaiteurs volentdidididids
pour en faire des armes.
Guy Marleau, professeur associé
en physique quoi que
le développement de l'énergie
nucléaire peut se faire en toute
sécurité.
GUY MARLEAU, professeur associé
au département de génie physique
- On est déjà dans le mouvement
vers une sécurité améliorée,
une réduction des déchets et
des nouveaux réacteurs
qui sont maintenant présentés
pour l'industrie sont beaucoup
plus sécuritaires que
les anciens réacteurs.
- Les détracteurs
de l'atome affirment
qu'il existe aujourd'hui
des options bien moins coûteuses
et plus vertes que l'énergie
nucléaire.
Mais surtout, ils s'opposent
aux discours vantant son côté
sécuritaire, car s'il est vrai
que les accidents nucléaires
restent rares, lorsqu'ils
surviennent, ils peuvent être
dévastateurs.
Ici Elisa Serret,
Radio-Canada, Montréa